[Musique]
le nouveau pont sans clé et construit
par un consortium dirigé par snc lavalin
malgré le nuage qui terni sa réputation
je peux vous et que we have un système
de cohésion oui ou non participer au
d'été des acteurs de sauts des
entreprises liées aux scandales de
collusion ou de corruption ont tout même
des contrats publics
il ya des entreprises sur lesquelles on
entendu des horreurs comme son
charbonneau on y voit encore travailler
aujourd'hui c'est à se demander
or on peut en déduire que l'autorité des
marchés financiers leur a donné
l'autorisation d'obtenir des contrats
publics au québec
lime f donne le feu vert à la firme
pourtant empêché à ottawa on signe des
ententes administratives avec elle un
lobby important et 7/10 vite et des
poursuites et d'obtenir des ententes à
l'amiable comme aux états unis
on fait vraiment une justice à deux
vitesses est là parce que ça donne le
message clair qui a été envoyé en 2011
en adoptant la loi concernant la lutte à
la corruption
trois ans plus tard on enlève finalement
toutes les dents à la législation
des changements législatifs importants
sont cachés dans des amendements adopté
en catimini pour protéger nos fleurons
les péquistes la caq où les libéraux y
en a pas un qui veut dire non à ces
choses là parce qu'ils veulent pas punir
leurs élites économiques
le système pour remettre les entreprises
au travail s'apparente au jeu de
certains michel serrault pacsés secret
on n'en sait rien et lassine justice
parallèle c'est un système de justice
extrajudiciaires
[Musique]
il avait reçu plusieurs paiements de la
société snc lavalin j'ai jamais en
aucune façon maintenant il ya plus de
deux ans nous avions dévoilé que cet
homme aurait accepté un pot-de-vin pour
donner le contrat de réfection du pont
jacques-cartier à snc lavalin c'était le
tournant de l'an 2000 il était le pdg de
la société des ponts champlain et
jacques-cartier
il est maintenant accusé de fraude mais
snc lavalin qui aurait donné le pot de
vin selon l' enquête de la grc n'est pas
inquiété c'est toujours le récepteur d'
enveloppe qui est puni et pau séduit le
donneur parce que en droit criminel le
donneur on doit avoir une intention
corruptrice pendant que michel fournier
bâti sa défense snc lavalin elle bâtit
le pont champlain un contrat de plus de
4 milliards de dollars
c'est business as du jour snc lavalin
qui est de nouveau dans l'embarras
la gendarmerie royale du canada dépose
des accusations de fraude et de
corruption contre la firme
l'entreprise est accusée d'avoir fraudé
la libye auprès de 130 millions $ et
d'aix aux dirigeants sont poursuivis
pour fraude dans le dossier du centre
universitaire de santé de mes guides
nous sommes non coupable à l'envoi se
battre jusqu'à la fin pour le démontrer
mais la fin est loin le procès
concernant la fraude alléguée en libye
n'est pas prévu avant trois ans le tout
pourrait s'éterniser jusqu'en 2025
pendant ce temps la snc lavalin aurait
été en pénitence incapable de travailler
au fédéral parfois baril à
l'international
snc lavalin crie au secours
l'aide
vivien d'ottawa sous la forme d'une
entente administrative et la lente
administratives vous permet de faire
quoi de soumissionner de continuer à
faire des contrats puis d'en gagner
encore d'autres jusqu'au bout des
pourcel jusqu'au bout des tours se tait
c'était la première entente de ce genre
à être signé en retour la firme a dû
mettre en place des règlements de
conformité anticorruption il y avait une
liste noire des entreprises proscrite de
faire affaire avec l'état
snc lavalin s'y trouvait ne pouvait pas
avoir la maîtrise d'oeuvre du pont
champlain
il y avait des concurrents étrangers qui
pressait pour avoir le contrat et le
gouvernement fait une exception à sa
propre loi pour permettre à snc de
d'avoir le contraire c'est de faire la
distinction entre ce que des individus
peuvent avoir fait est une entreprise
alors des individus qui ont fait de la
main 20 stations doivent être poursuivis
doivent payer des pénalités doivent
rembourser l'argent doivent aller en
prison si c'est le cas mais les
entreprises elles doivent continuer à
opérer pour donner des emplois
ottawa et québec lui marne le même
langage
on ne peu d'entreprises globales on a
senti la balle est donc bien sûr nouveau
niveau on n'a pas partie réservé aux
noeuds ce que je dis moi simplement
c'est que soyons prudents avec nos
grands fleuves et pour cela le
gouvernement québécois va assouplir ses
lois anti-corruption 2011 2012
plusieurs entreprises ont été mises sur
la sellette à la commission charbonneau
tech à 2010 au caire 9 838 22 ans ou est
ce que vous êtes en mesure de l'audience
c'est un appel d'offres truqués ou nos
trucs
[Musique]
ainsi en est il de la collusion a légué
des quatre grands dans le domaine des
conduites d'eau et des égouts
ce qui aurait augmenté les coûts de 85%
ventech et d'autres qui auraient payé
des pots-de-vin aux ingénieurs de la
ville de montréal pour obtenir des
contrats travaille encore tous les films
qui étaient bien longueuil faisait
partie du système de collusion
même scénario pour des sous les verrous
vilipendé à la commission charbonneau
réhabilité par la mf pourtant dans la
foulée de la commission
le ton des parties étaient assez
unanimes il est totalement inacceptable
que des fraudes a peut s'obtenir des
contrats publics financés à même
l'argent des québécois
nous convions tous les québécois et
québécoises un grand ménage un premier
ménage a été fait en 2011
rappelez-vous le gouvernement libéral
voulait éviter la commission charbonneau
qu'un s'agit de collusion de corruption
de mafieuses rahmane a fait plus pour
faire taire la grogne public et s'en
faut mais plutôt à la police avec neil
back et adopte une loi qui crée un
registre d'entreprise coupable pour se
retrouver dans la complexité des lois
qui vont se succéder
nous avons demandé l'aide d'une
spécialiste en introduit le rena le
registre des entreprises non admissibles
s'y trouvent les contractantes déclaré
coupable d'une infraction
donc ce qui est important c'est ça
coupables déclaré coupable oui ok donc
inadmissible pour les contrats publics
pour cinq ans
le coup de filet qui est donné avec le
rena attrape quelques gros poissons
mais ce sont plutôt des centaines de
petits qui sont pris pour des
infractions mineures de petits commerces
qui ont tenté d'éviter la taxe d'accise
[Musique]
la commission charbonneau vient de
commencer et frappent l'imaginaire des
citoyens une de ces régles c'était de
payer une cote au clan sicilien
oui j'y vois je ne voulais pas vous
payer je ne confirmerai pas non plus que
je ne cautionne pour le pôle exclure a
coûté 6 a été le corps ggp à lui est en
train de nous dire que vous étiez un
baisser les incompétents
le parti québécois prend le pouvoir et
serre la vis avec une nouvelle loi anti
corruption
nous voulons créer un deuxième registre
tenu par la mfc l'orage est des
entreprises autorisées qu'on appelle
maintenant le rire dans nos arénas
ça c'est les entreprises nos ennemis
c'est fait on all rien oui alors le rena
c'est le conseil du trésor c'est pour
les entreprises qui sont déclarés
coupables d'une infraction est lauréat
c'est un registre des entreprises qui
ont été autorisés par la msa obtenir des
contrats au delà d'un certain seuil
au delà de 5 millions de dollars les
entreprises doivent demander une
autorisation pour obtenir un contrat
public
l'upac enquête et c'est là mêmes qui
décident
elle doit refuser l'autorisation à
contracter ses juges que l'entreprise ne
satisfait pas aux exigences élevées
d'intégrité auquel le public est en
droit de s'attendre
c'est comme cela que bintec comme
d'autres vont aussi se retrouver dans le
filet du rena et vont commencer à jouer
à serpents et échelles entre les deux
registres ainsi entreprises ventech
demande à la mf de l'autoriser à
soumissionner aux contrats publics être
ennemis sur lauréat mais la mf refuse
question d'intégrité
conséquence elles glissent sur le rena 5
en pénitence c'est automatique
l'entreprise s'est adressé à la cour
pour forcer la main à la mf mais a perdu
c'est avec le procès qu'on découvre un
peu les critères de la f1 si elle juge
que la firme pp entreprises bencheikh
n'est qu'une façade pour construction
ventech dont ils attentent été question
à la commission charbonneau une façade
car hélas la même adresse et pas
d'équipement mais tout n'est pas perdu
pour entreprise b tech en 2015
les libéraux reprennent le pouvoir et
modifie à nouveau les règles avec une
loi aux trolls de titres au jeu de l'oie
numéro 26 loi visant principalement la
récupération des sommes payées 1
jusqu'en 1 à la suite de fraudes ou de
manoeuvres dolosives dans le cadre de
contrats publics selon titre cache
quelque chose parce que c'est ajouter
dans des dispositions modificatrice à la
toute fin de la loi qui n'a en fait
aucun lien avec l'objectif principal de
la loi pour la récupération des sommes
disait des articles clés mais
incompréhensible vont détricoter les
lois précédentes vous manque un joli
zola et modifiée par tel article de tête
chapitre on fait référence à un autre
chapitre nos lois alors on dit qu'elle
est modifiée par l'ajout après l'article
58 points qui lui a été édictée par
l'article 23 du chapitre 25 des lois de
2002 vivement la tête et fois inversé
des articles donc il faut prendre le
temps il faut prendre le temps mais je
pense que ce qui est ce qui est ce qui
peut problématique si c'est le message
que lance cette modification la
l'autorité des marchés financiers de
vieilles la commission des libérations
conditionnelles des entreprises parce
qu'elle va décider si oui ou non
l'entreprise est suffisamment
réhabiliter malgré qu'elle ait sur le
rena
une entreprise peut maintenant demander
en tout temps de passer d'une liste à
l'autre grimpée du rena aurea
et pendant que la mf évalue la demande
l'entreprise est automatiquement retirée
du rena éligibles soudainement à
soumissionner
et c'est ainsi que entreprises ventech a
pu demander de nouveau à la mf
l'autorisation de soumissionner aux
contrats publics grimper au real ce
qu'elle a obtenu
elle signe immédiatement un contrat avec
la ville de montréal
sept cent cinquante mille dollars pour
refaire une conduite d'eau vérification
faite
l'équipement a été louée d'une
entreprise à numéros liés à construction
ventech alors comment at elle pu obtenir
le feu vert de la mf puisqu'on lui
reprochait justement de ne pas avoir son
équipement l'entreprise peut démontrer
qu'elle satisfait aux critères
d'intégrité
si elle ou par exemple elle se
débarrasse de l'actionnaire qui est une
personne physique qui a été déclaré
coupable ou un des administrateurs ou
dirigeants qui faisait problème une
grande entreprise qui se débarrasse de
l'actionnaire ou de l'administrateur
considérer malhonnête peut remonter
l'échelle
c'est ce qu'ont fait des sauts et snc
lavalin
quant à entreprises bintec impossible de
savoir ce qu'elle a fait pour être
blanchi d'un contre qui étaient truquées
et j'ai reçu je devais 3000 $ de la part
de monsieur antonio bentivegna monsieur
tony bentivegna antonio banderas est ce
que c'est toujours lui qui faisait
affaire avec vous pour ces choses-là nos
jours
tony bentivegna un senior aurait donné
des pots de vin aux ingénieurs de
montréal pour obtenir des contrats pour
des entreprises de ses enfants
c'est son fils qu'on voit dans ces
images et qui porte le même nom qui est
aux commandes d'entreprises ventech qui
travaille de nouveau un mot rien joint
au téléphone ce dernier réfute tout ce
qui a été dit à la commission qu'est ce
que vous avez fait pour que l'autorité
des marchés financiers la mmf vous
accorde l'autorisation à sanctionner
cela restera un secret entre la
compagnie et la mfb n'tech n'a jamais
été poursuivi
c'est son intégrité qui était questionné
mais avec la nouvelle loi même être
reconnus coupables ne veut plus rien
dire non autorisée déclaré coupable
c'est plus un super u refus automatique
et les entreprises a été découvert par
un tribunal étranger
c'est plus un refuge c'est plus un refus
automatique c'est un refus et on va le
voir plus loin un refus discrétionnaire
donc c'est peut considérer un pouvoir
accru pour la mf qui n'a pas à expliquer
ces décisions publiques
elle doit toutefois prévenir les
entreprises d'un éventuel refus ce qui
permet un échappatoire comme nous
l'avons découvert l'entreprise n'a alors
qu à se désister
cela lui évite de glisser au reina
vu ni connu c'est ce qu'ont fait plus de
300 entreprises sont s'ils conservent
leur droit de soumissionner sur tous les
contrats de moins de 5 millions de
dollars 5 millions c'est le seuil pour
toutes les municipalités
sauf montréal qui la dcl à 100 mille
dollars
il ya donc du travail pour des
entreprises même sans l'autorisation de
la mf et celles qui l'ont sont peu
surveillés ont dit un manque de
ressources donc le follow up
c'est donc votre agent de probation ne
vous appelle pas très souvent un sens on
peut dire dans ce sens-là émis à
vérification selon lui pâques que
lorsque des drapeaux sont levés et pas
systématiquement
ainsi seuls quatre entreprises ont été
sanctionnés les entreprises veulent plus
elles veulent gagner au jeu de serpents
et échelles et le gros loup serait les
dpa pour des fautes pour ses clichés
negri min autrement dit des ententes à
l'amiable payer une amende éviterait
toute poursuite
basé sur le modèle américain ces
ententes représente le saint graal pour
les entreprises qui ont des ennuis
ça va te coûter 500 millions par exemple
et et en échange de ce paiement là tu
vas mettre en place dans ta compagnie
des codes d'éthique des mesures pour de
lutte à la corruption et tous vont
embaucher des vérificateurs externes qui
vont en voir l'application est donc en
échange de sol et compagnie elle évite
toute poursuite criminelle
elle n'est pas trouvée coupable de rien
et elle peut continuer à soumissionner
et avoir des contrats de l'état et
d'autres organismes internationaux
[Musique]
c'est un mettrait fin à la poursuite
contre et c'est pour la fraude présumée
en libye je pense que autant pour le
gouvernement que pour un seul a valu de
très longues procédures parce que des
procès comme ça c'est toujours long ce à
des coûts importants pour le
gouvernement et pour nous
tandis qu'avec un dpe on peut régler
beaucoup plus rapidement québec a déjà
fait un premier pas dans cette direction
cette démarche leur vise à éviter ou sid
encombrer nos tribunaux judiciaires la
loi 26 celle avec un drôle de nom
prévoit justement le remboursement de
sommes que des organismes vélo ministère
auraient payé entre ou à des entreprises
sans intenter de poursuite
c'est un bon exemple à la manière des dp
et c'est une justice extrajudiciaires
opaque
nobody knows entre snc lavalin a été une
des premières entreprises à participer à
ce programme et au moment où vous aurez
réglé pour le programme de remboursement
volontaire vous êtes prêt à admettre
combien dangereux mais nous c'est pas
nous qui décidons s'associer le
programme alors que le gouvernement a
décidé c'est qu'à la toute fin
quand tout le monde sera passée dans le
processus ils vont dévoiler le montant
d'argent
les ententes de type dpa rapporte
beaucoup dans les coffres publics
mais avec la loi 26 le montant remboursé
par chacune des entreprises ne sera
jamais connue
et ce programme est temporaire et le
moment c'est pas mieux quand même des
payer qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement avec les changements qui
ont été apportés aux lois québécoises
parce qu'ils sont autorisés à
soumissionner
même s'ils sont poursuivis même s'ils
ont été trouvés coupables est ce que
c'est pour mieux des pays alors que ce
moment à l'eau ça serait mieux ce serait
mieux
un lobby important est menée dans ce
sens par rien de moins que john manley
l'ex vice premier ministre du canada au
nom du conseil canadien des affaires
snc-lavalin en est le fer de lance de
beaucoup de lobby d'affaires
on demande un changement législatif pas
seulement pour snc-lavalin mais pour les
entreprises canadiennes pour pouvoir
compétitionner à l'international avec le
même cadre réglementaire que nos grands
compétiteurs qui eux sont basés aux
états unis en grande bretagne ou en
france où là ils ont ce type de loi aux
états unis ces ententes ont rapporté 40
milliards de dollars en quinze ans ce
qui les rend populaire
mais sont-elles efficaces pour lutter
contre la corruption pour plusieurs
entreprises qui sont là dedans si rien
ça c'est rien ça donne c'est un drop in
the eastern asset une goutte dans
l'océan payer ces quelques centaines de
millions d'amande et que c'est comme une
taxe à la corruption quand on a des
actionnaires c'est au jour deux coups
d'argent alors moi je n'appelle pas ça
une taxe à la corruption
et doit-on s'enligner sur les lois
américaines
cet argument là qui dit qu' en droit en
matière de lutte à la corruption les
états doivent adobe ajuster leurs droits
ceux des américains
ben il faut faire attention parce que
depuis que l'administration trompette au
pouvoir plusieurs mesures de lutte à la
corruption ont été recensés ont été
défaites
donc si nos entreprises dit il faut
s'ajuster au droit américain
attention car là c'est l' open bar de la
corruption potentiellement
un fragile équilibre à trouver entre
sauver nos fleurons lutter contre la
corruption
dp a fait la différence en des
accusations auprès d'individus versus
une entreprise alors on s'est parlé de à
sion d'un des payeurs de même atteint ça
n'empêche pas que les individus qui sont
actuellement poursuivis au criminel vont
continuer à l'être
c'est ce moment l'entreprise qui ne le
sera pas c'est qu'avec le haut c'est
vrai qu'on va pas détruire nos
entreprises à être plus moraux que les
autres n'est ce pas mon point
les politiciens doivent être
transparents là dessus en dire on va
adopter des lois comme le dit pied
on ne sait pas si ça va être efficace
pour faire en sorte que les entreprises
ne veulent plus faire de la corruption
sont le cpo vraiment mais on sait que ça
va équilibrer les intérêts économiques
et la lutte à la corruption
[Musique]